لأنها تأتي كما تأتي لأنها بعيدة
كانت واسعة ، كانت تضيق في المنزل ، ها هي
شعر بالارتياح عندما جاء
[موسيقى]
قال ماذا تفعل هنا
قال إنه يمكنك الطيران فقلت إننا لا نطير
قلت إن الوقوف هنا لن يكون مثل هذا
قال إنك ستسقط قدمك تنزلق أو شيء من هذا القبيل
قال
[موسيقى]
التكلفة التقريبية لتلك المنصة 300 ألف
TL نحن 3 ملايين 30 مليون
لقد قمنا باستثمارات ، يجب أن تكون هذه الاستثمارات
جعلنا سعداء جدا ولكن هذا 300 ألف
من دواعي سروري استثماري
السلام وهذا ما أعطانا
السعادة لا تستثمر
لم يحدث ذلك لأن هذا هو السبب
هناك روح في الاستثمار ، لذا فإليك أ
معاق عقليا وجسديا
هز الطفل المصاب بإعاقة على ظهره
من تأهيله بالتسلق على السرير
من يتسامح معه يحظى بيوم جيد
من أم تناضل من أجلها
مصنوعة من إجلال لطفل معاق
قيمة في أن تكون من الولاء
موجود
[موسيقى]